تركيا ترد على شروط رئيس النظام السوري
بشار الاسد للقاء نظيره التركي وتقول انها
غير مناسبه لمسار استعاده تطبيع العلاقات
الثنائيه التي انقطعت منذ بدايه الحرب في
سوريا فمن ينوي التفاهم والتفاوض لا يرفع
سقف المطالب بحسب مسؤولين اتراك
[موسيقى]
اعاده الوضع الى ما كان عليه قبل بدء
الحرب في سوريا هذا هو
هذه هي الحاله الوحيده التي يمكن عندها ان
يكون هناك لقاء بيني وبينها
عدا عن ذلك ما هي قيمه هذا اللقاء ولماذا
نقوم به ان لم يكن سيحقق نتائج نهائيه
بالنسبه للحرب في سوريا
بين شروط يطرحها الاسد وتعنت تركي تبقى
جهود موسكو لعقد القمه بين الرئيسين الا
ان اخر تصريحات الاسد قد تضرب بتلك الجهود
عرض الحائط قائلا ان بلاده قد تصل الى
حوار على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه او حتى
معاونهم
سنوات من الحرب هزت العلاقه السوريه
التركيه حتى الانقطاع ولم يبقى الى خيط
رفيع بين انقره ودمشق تحاول موسكو الان
اعاده ربطه الا ان الاسد في حاله انتظار
لما بعد الانتخابات التركيه مراهنا على
خساره اردوغان امام مرشح المعارضه كما
الكليتشارد الى عمر العربيه